[Musica]
rispetto al fine di non sa che cosa
pensate quando sentite parlare di queste
due parole sicuramente a un processo a
una strategia ma esternato da un'azienda
per trasformarsi appunto di diventare
avanzata il fatto di tecnologia digitale
appunto così dove stavamo in essi
andriano iniziata per banali mentale
oggi la rete innovativa e più importante
gli italiani fattore di pagamenti e
digitali processo strategie tecnologia
digitale appunto queste sono le parole
più utilizzate che aspettiamo quando
studiamo parlare di questa
trasformazione meglio oggi vi chiedo di
fare uno sforzo significa 32 parma
sicuramente di visitare ma non lo
realizzano dimenticate le giunte tallinn
una trasformazione concentrandosi
mancano sull'ultimo dalla però
trasformare al di là e forma aspetto
quella è la formazione è un concetto che
ho commentato specifico che riguarda
un generico cambiamento ci parla di una
trasformazione che è un mutamento nella
forma eventi nell'aspetto esteriore
certamente la forte qualcosa di
fondamentale per destinarli un oggetto
di un animale che quindi pesce è mutata
ma nella trasformazione la sostanza non
cambia
incatenati o meglio può essere soggetta
a variazioni ricombinazioni aggiunte
perdite ma ci deve essere un nocciolo un
nocciolo che diventa un filo conduttore
per questa trasformazione
e sapete qual è non solo di un'azienda
che si può trasformare sono proprio le
persone le persone ficale cameri
comportamenti cambiano le competenze
canali interazioni e cambiando questo
non solo
cambia la forma di questa settimana la
trasformazione digitale quindi essi un
processo che non è una strategia e
riguarda sicuramente ecologia
ma in definitiva soprattutto per
cambiare servono le persone e le loro
vetture
[Musica]
oggi voglio condividere con voi 10
aspetti 10 sfide importanti che ogni
azienda deve affrontare per trasformarsi
e mutare la sua cultura
in primis connettere le competenze
un'azienda italiana deve portare nel suo
bagaglio competenze innovative spesso
sui giovani o comunque visitabile la
parte difficile è connettere le potete
nuota e che diversi tra loro e passiti
queste competenze interagiscano con le
altre persone presenti di animazione di
molti litigi dove ricevono sicuramente
più famose inflazionati un antico fare
in modo che lavorino bene insieme e il
passato nella staffetta sia un elemento
valore piuttosto da un'altura proprio
nello sport se ci siamo lo sport
permettere ad esempio la staffetta
perché è proprio nella staffetta di più
ostinate vincerla metteva assieme sprint
che non hanno mai gareggiato assieme
quindi ricordiamo le questioni tipi
mancini 50 riuscire a localizzare detto
questo meccanismo di squadra anche
quelli di competenze scritta al non sono
ma che si sposta al vecchio sistema e
negli aziende che sono le persone
anziane sono le persone anziane alle
loro conoscenze che fino a quel momento
non portato l'azienda ha colpito e
rappresentano quindi una metafora che
non è questa la proposta
la velocità le velocità sono quindi il
secondo aspetto rischierebbe di citare
sempre un'azienda è una cosa
fondamentale
ma che cosa parliamo i giovani con le
loro bagaglio di competenze di chi
parlava prima innovative contro
tradizionali moda ma rappresenti sterno
a polarizzare ok velocità diversi in
azienda
pasqua esempio c'è un team molto
performante che va velocissimo freddo di
concetto papa a termine in tempo e messi
su un altro film un po più lento e fa
fatica a raggiungere gli obiettivi le
velocità quindi vanno gestite perché
altrimenti si dice che queste persone
vadano strategie e quelli medi si
stanchino e quelli veloci si stufino si
fidano e molto importante sistema delle
città
un po come una storia di ciclismo in una
tappa di montagna per chi conosce il pc
che
ciclismo dove il singolo delle carriere
l'alta velocità non si può dimenticare
per la squadra quindi è fondamentale
terzo terza sfida i muri i muri intese
come barriere
oppure semplicemente come silos le
aziende meno note ma di quelle ferite e
sono piena di sempre e riguardano i
processi perché le mosse pensieri nei
processi regole strutture comportamenti
a queste stesse al temono che però
rispetto alla trasformazione risultante
di travolte da un mese soprattutto per
silvio ecco bisogna a parte questi
momenti
oppure che lascia giorno assolutamente
domicilio
persino ma prima di tutto il particolare
momento avevano stesso ma oggi devono
trovare un altro stesso e quindi se
rischio abbattere tutti questi muri sono
le proprie macerie
pazienza perché rischio vale di parlanti
si apre all di questi utili
essenzialmente parola che si apre
appunto le innovazioni che rossi da fa
in un luogo di camerieri per tipologia
appunto chi di voi i processi che
cambiano i problemi di connessioni di
velocità tra persone diverse
perché poi alla fine in diritto a
semplici caratteristiche speciali
un altro tema politico tante e su questo
che faccio da un upgrade line è tutt ora
sono scusati di un gruppo di designer e
movimenti delle informazioni partecipare
al cambiamento significa rendere parte e
bendati parte vuol dire che le persone
si devono sentire coinvolte non ci può
essere di 150 neo laureati colpite
[Musica]
costruito questo decimo anno e non è
superata rimanga parte anche qui oltre a
testate l'azienda tipi dante sul
processo di segreto del successo è la
protezione di queste persone è di fare
picco e quindi di propagare informazioni
non devono restare sulle loro scrivanie
e queste succedere giunto con giorni ma
la nota di carità cosa sta succedendo
sul mercato quali sono i progetti di
successo quali sono i fari mettere più
parare ci sono un sacco di cose che non
possono restare nella stanza dei bottoni
vasto data la prima partita l'inter a
queste informazioni devono tornare in
alto generalmente essere morto ma è uno
straniere devono salire dalle persone
per chi fa veramente le cose perché le
persone stefano e sentieri
un'appartenenza appartenenza come per un
tifoso perché viene una spalla che viene
all'inter
la partenza importante e quindi
personale non sentisse parti di questo
campionato
e importantissimo
la partenza sarebbe quello che questo
atteggiamento consentì fusa naturale ma
in realtà non lo è e non lo è non solo
le aziende non lo è perché c'è una
tendenza umanissima abbiamo sentito
anche un po prima di resistere a questo
cambiamento
la stessa s sia in discesa
istantaneamente perché che si disegna
nazionali con forse quest'anno tali
costi ok per costruita in anni e anni di
fatica e quando io esco fuori da questa
calamità o poi può succedere e quindi
spesso magari coscia ci sono dei
comportamenti che queste persone e da no
ad esistere e creano dei comportamenti
resistenza ma la cosa importante da
ricordarsi e che oggi processo di
innovazione giovani coratini scatta oggi
stiamo parlando prima parte sempre da
mettere in discussione il passato è il
passato comunque resta
non rinnega ripassatina partire dal
passato e quindi con un pedine viene
criticato perché se vogliamo innovare
bisogna ad identificarlo insegnamento
discussione e quindi tra virgolette si
mette in discussione il lavoro che hanno
fatto le persone e cina per momenti sono
state da sempre insieme
ed ecco l'ennesimo questo in questo
stesso uno scontro tra da un lato c'è
chi preme per innovare e magari anche
stato assunto contro l'obiettivo e
magari neanche iniziato dall'altra parte
invece ct sia morta su delle posizioni e
difendersi su quel passato era stato
costruito io ad esempio primo sei mesi
sette mesi in azienda mi sono trovato da
solo dove costruire un clima tutti
denuncerà ho combattuto tantissimo con
queste persone che si erano imbarcate ma
inconsciamente perché proprio molto meno
forse una vuole però è soprattutto in
questi momenti di difficoltà perché
libri della punto fuoco e gli strumenti
difficoltà mentito
si innesca anch'esso in maniera attuale
un atteggiamento che è che quello
proprio contrario alla resistenza e
analisi utilizzata quindi le persone
tutti di lavoro che si aggregano quel
punto perché se parliamo di propagare le
informazioni se parliamo di condividere
se parliamo di strettissima per
l'espressione inconsciamente di natale
eventi situazioni con le istituzioni si
parla di quanto la finalità di
un'azienda è fatta di progetti che
fatichi e che accolgono cambiamento lo
ha fatto non lavorarci perché importante
a baciare cambiamento e formano
inconsciamente anche qui dell'eredità
dei comandamenti da seguire e condivido
non abbiamo fatti siano quindi
partecipano all'estrazione dell'azienda
quindi di zucchero nelle stesse e rapina
sfidante bisogna illudere nelle
esistenze
i fasti di queste esistenze si
trasformino residenze se volessimo dare
ad un alto dirigente d'azienda
potremmo definirlo alcune un organismo
economico fatto da persone e cose che
hanno degli scopi determinati a questa
descrizione che troviamo sul fantastico
ma sono tre fattori importanti
l'organismo ma niente e le persone
c'è una scienza che studia queste
considerazioni i modelli e definisce
l'insieme di queste forze ecologia
quindi la stessa sfida è trasformare
l'ecologia e l'ambiente azienda per
permettere persone di trasformarsi se
non ha mai chiostra trovati molti
collegate che vadano tutti la sua casa
gli archetti uffici e scrivanie i colori
ho fatto io anche a girandole pollici
oppure a parte per i polsi avessero la
fit ha concesso le persone è un
grandissimo abilitatore ok per far parte
di questo sistema la libertà
e superati da un grande acceleratore
alla creatività di educazione passate
non sono levate in azienda tutti
portavano avanti oppure c'era la
sinistra di solo per i genitori e il
punto è cominciato nel cromatismo e così
io a volte vado anche nella misura della
regata
eppure in grande un grande sentimento di
libertà da parte nieri preparare non
sempre però il colletto bianco e quindi
il settimo è una grandissima una
grandissima questione e controllare il
linguaggio controllando in quanto perché
anche tutto vero linguaggio è sempre un
fattore di tecnologia le nostre aziende
parlano dei linguaggi complessissimi io
non sono arrivato ci fosse ancora adesso
non so arrivavano da pivot certe cose
perché gli esempi sono interpreti
foresterie gli acronimi in si
partecipano regioni si siede e un
liquido presentare
il supporto della superficie che per
questo è un problema è un problema di
tipologia il linguaggio e petit spesso
queste vengono utilizzate perché sempre
persone un po per pigrizia un po perché
il dramma di qualche comune quesito
sostituisce il significato significante
contentissima prove e poi pensi che le
persone state formano idee che spesso
riferire un dettagliato in persone e una
donna in realtà il sangue non tanto per
dire che l'arte è una parte divertente
sulla di pantano e se dessimo indietro
adesso vi faccio un esempio
dobbiamo desiderare di bordighera norme
della sua utilizzazione adesso marie
claire settimana non vuol dire che molti
elementi e quindi il problema che si
parla così negli uffici delle
trasformazioni
dell'azienda ma che in realtà si sta
semplicemente dicendo credo la carta
aiutato virtualizzata ficca dentro ci
sono tantissimi modi di poter dire
appunto e liberare da un porting è la
norma l'autorizzazione
quindi queste righe colli raggirano
ostacolano ok senza una reale necessità
annuncia necessità la gente si crede
figlia scusate sa usare i vestiti
secondi e derubate te perché ti fa
toccano barriere vede fuori dall'azienda
perché poi il creato dire azienda quanto
le persone ma se poi 11 in patria che
non è di fare molti posti un progetto i
racconti qualcosa e magari mi chiamare
quello che si fatica a trovarlo
non trovando di empatia e che dire
davvero che cosa devo fare ancora e
quindi la sfida per cambiare è
accogliere ogni giorno questa
complessità vestirci questi linguaggi e
cercare questo e questa è una cosa che
chiedevano un originale ogni persona
ricerca di rendere questi linguaggi
complessi
ok molto più semplici perché poi si
possono dire in tanti modi in un
percorso di trasformazione di poi una
delle prime azioni da compiere
soprattutto se si vuole iniziare a
muovere un po le genti le foglie e
questo succede succede anche nella
politica proprio franci politica è
cambiare i vicini vicini quindi portate
cambiare i generici da degli obiettivi
vogliamo diventare leader
saremo fare
ok però come ci si arriva come arriviamo
a darci degli obiettivi e fa subito
subiti che mi siano stati costanti
traducibili in valori e comportamenti
nei quali sempre le persone si possono
riconoscere dei valori dovrebbe essere
si possono riconoscere nella
quotidianità anche nello sport propri
figli dello sport personale e poi
possono attesi e poi possono dare il
fattivo contributo sia un valore
ma io quello altro segno e quindi non
appartengo e di qui contributo posso
darmi nessuno perché non lo scopo mino
quindi importante che le gambe dei
valori che siano semplici telefoni
sentono il cast di nancy faccio un
esempio che sono tre sembrano stupidi
maritano sono molto concreti essere
affidabili essere semplici ospiti di
vivere quindi a sfidare apple tv dei
valori per contribuire singolo anche dal
caminetto complessivo alle 16 47 c ma in
pochi semplici e diventare leader di
mercato allora che siano raggiungibili
giorno dopo giorno e che possano affitti
appartenere alla rovina
ma sono ancora stati così perfetto che
io non è riuscito a sfumare uno sparti
diritti 50 sono il tenente cd sto
raccontando solo quello che io ti sto
per realizzare le aziende precedenti
analizzare adesso nessi cambiare
un'azienda con il professore gradivano è
un percorso complesso e tortuoso clienti
problemi i problemi non mancano ma chi
sono le vie dei giorni del sal mente il
ricordo di manager negato al suo compito
logico e risolvere problemi esistono a
bizzeffe e garanti amici ci sono dei
trasporti ma un problema che hanno in
cui esistono dei problemi noti e le
istruzioni di letteratura ta quindi
esistere frattura programma molto bene
trovare una soluzione ma esistono
soprattutto problemi questi sconosciuti
vi è il si pongono problemi di
sconosciuti ostacoli a quality spesso lo
fu all'inizio ok fare leva
sull'immaginazione quindi bisogna
lavorare tanto
il pensiero laterale e quindi fare le
stimolare queste persone cultura che
abbiamo
ok in modo tale che queste persone con
la loro immaginazione e riescano a
trovare una soluzione creare soluzioni
quindi e provare tale pratica
nel mio caso chi lo sapeva come si
creavano lupo di cartone suddivisi in
azienda che da 25 anni faceva parlamento
in italia e la nuova appena fatto che
non lo sapevo non solo perché suonare
con un contesto
eppure che io ei miei colleghi per
quelli presenti stava male hanno fatto
costruendo giorno dopo giorno lo stesso
martin e senza seguire un modo superando
gli standard quindi vediamo ora se c'è
il gusto
[Musica]
[Applauso]
l'ultima sfida invece una cosa abbiamo
toccato e che permette ossessione aura
di queste dieci sfide perché le aziende
devono affrontare per per la sua base ed
è fare fallire e mi fa noi siamo fatti
questo agnano queste informazioni
siamo fatti per imparato e siamo fatti
per cui altri
l'unico modo che ha un'azienda per
trasformarsi non è solo accettare il
fallimento oggi perché tesi verna per
rischio delegati punti difficile
accettare di fallimento ma in realtà lo
devono stimolare lo devono conoscere
stimolare a far fallire per rifare
perché da questo perché per me oggi dato
un'altra
l'unica cosa che ho imparato davvero in
questi anni della boe logico sono
giovane ma la verità di cdc anni e che
ho fallito senza stelle potevano fare ok
e così questo è stato un successo delle
aziende che sono stato cresciuto lì ho
sbagliato voluto dal fatto una scelta
[Musica]
quindi per chiudere la formazione in
azienda
a questo punto loro riguarda processi
strategie digitali non libri la stampa
ma riguarda soprattutto le persone e le
loro culture sono le persone comuni noi
i capelli rossi
[Applauso]